hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
take a close look at this scene
it looks just like any other movie scene
but it's actually a recreation of a
scene in the matrix but it's made
entirely within a game engine
yeah so what you might be thinking
you might also be thinking while tech
demos look realistic they're always
pre-rendered and they use visual tricks
just to make it seem more realistic
but what if i told you that this was
running in real time and running on
console hardware right now today on the
ps5 xbox series x and even series s
scenes like this highlight what's so
exciting about unreal engine 5 by epic
games
a few days ago they showcased a matrix
game concept and its purpose was to show
that the future of gaming has indeed
arrived just take a look at this
this is what i imagine the games of the
future would look like as a kid
so i'm really excited about this
in this episode we'll take a look at
what was shown as well as some other
unreal engine 5 information and then
we'll see what this means for the future
of gaming let's get into it
[Music]
when we last visited unreal engine 5 i
showed many aspects of what was nearly
possible but there are a number of
people in the comments section who just
couldn't believe it they thought cinema
quality gaming was still 20 years away
later on in that very episode i showed
that unreal engine was indeed capable of
cinema quality film productions it was
already being utilized by amateur
filmmakers with incredible results and
we'll see another one of those at the
end of the episode but i guess the
commenters in the last video just didn't
watch the whole thing epic games must
have experienced something similar on
social media because this matrix demo
was made as a direct response to the
people who just didn't believe that the
last demo was real they wanted to show
that their technology was feasible
let's just take a second to observe and
appreciate just how far graphics have
come with this engine observe the detail
and the presence of the light and how it
makes it feel like it's a real place and
not just flat like most graphics
[Music]
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so as mentioned in the last episode
there are two main technologies here
that make this a step above what was
previously possible in the gaming
industry
the first technology is lumen a
real-time lighting solution that mimics
the way light bounces in the real world
but it's achieved in such a way that
it's less of a burden than traditional
ray tracing
previously i mentioned lighting is a key
aspect that sets video game graphics
apart from pre-rendered pixar movies now
both of them can have that presence and
realism but the game is free to run in
real time
to showcase the real-time lighting
effects in the demo there are settings
where users can play with the sun's
location and see for themselves how it
affects the world
the second technology is nanite
this allows for the polygon limit to
largely be removed from games and this
is huge
until now game developers were limited
by the number of polygons that they
could have in one scene the more you
have the more detailed it can be
but if you add too many it begins to
slow the system down so it was a
trade-off between artistic fidelity and
gaming performance
but this is no longer the case
with the polygon limit removed
everything is extremely detailed all the
time and crazy things are possible
the city in this demo comprises of seven
million assets made up of millions of
polygons each
there are 7 000 buildings and there are
over 45 000 part cars not to mention the
cars that are driving around
there are 260 kilometers of road and 512
kilometers of
sidewalk for the first time such a vast
amount of detail can be rendered and
played all at once in real time
objects popping in and out of view as
the player gets closer is largely a
thing of the past
buildings often the distance can remain
detailed
so how does nanite work well according
to epic games quote during importing
meshes are analyzed and broken down into
hierarchical clusters of triangle groups
during rendering clusters are swapped
out on the fly at varying levels of
detail based on the camera view and
connect perfectly without cracks to
neighbouring clusters within the same
object
data is streamed on demand so that only
visible detail needs to reside in memory
nanite runs in its own rendering pass
that completely bypasses traditional
drawcall
and just to highlight how much detail
there is john lineman from
digitalfoundry says that it's the first
playable game that a scene with a chain
link fence that has modeled geometry and
not just a texture
with the polygon limit removed there's
now creative room to do more things like
this where with previous technology such
things would have been a massive waste
of resources
another technology we touched on last
time was metahuman and that's unreal
engine 5's character building solution
in the matrix demo it's proved itself in
ways that i wouldn't have expected so
both keanu reeves and carrie anne moss
had their faces photo scanned in but the
third character in the back of the car
is a stock meta human character
epic games wanted to show that metahuman
characters could be right beside
digitally scanned assets and still hold
up
there's also other technology built on
top of unreal engine 5 that is frankly
incredible
zrt face trainer uses unreal engine 5
combined with ai trained on 4d movement
data to create cgi puppets and they give
some amazing results just take a look at
this face
[Music]
when metahuman is combined with blender
the results are also amazing
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i do also want to talk about the chaos
engine in unreal it enables real-time
destruction
in this car chase scene when a car
crashes and rolls it's not something
that's pre-rendered and controlled by
the vision of the artists it's the
actual physics engine at work the same
goes for the glass breaking in the rear
mirror
the publication digital foundry did some
tests with the playthrough and found
that when cars exploded or rolled each
time was different and unique
there's also an interesting scene in the
demo where neo is on the roof dodging a
projectile according to the verge epic
games managed to find the original
warner brothers neo asset and import it
into unreal engine 5.
they literally combined a cinematic
model with a real-time game engine
i think that's incredible and i don't
think it's something we've ever seen
before
interestingly the city was procedurally
generated based on algorithmic rules
this meant that the game designers and
developers didn't have to painstakingly
manually place every object building or
road it was done semi-automatically
freeing up more time for other things
like fine-tuning of the world and in the
future in the case of a real game
working on the actual story for once
epic games is giving this matrix world
away for free all the assets and all the
code so users can modify it till their
heart's content so i think that's pretty
cool and we'll have to see what people
come up with
speaking of story and creativity the
amateur film community using unreal
engine 5 is really starting to ramp up i
think this is definitely going to be a
space to watch have a look and you know
what i mean
[Music]
[Music]
one more day rex and we're going home
receiving coordinates now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
of course it's my last day and i have to
go into a dark scary cave
let's just do this
so it all can't be roses right
there has to be some bad stuff here well
i've noticed three main weaknesses
when driving fast or smashing into a lot
of cars there can be frame rate drops
epic games is aware of this issue and
says that it's looking to make
improvements and optimizations before
the release of the engine
the second one is metahuman seems to be
its weakest point the way people walk
and the way the main character runs in
the free roam section is a little clunky
but maybe this is being worked on as
well
and the last thing i noticed is that
reflections in the distance sometimes
flicker and this is especially
noticeable at night
as said before this is a work in
progress and they're still fine-tuning
before the official release of unreal
engine 5.
so in summary i think it's safe to say
that next gen has finally arrived
during my first viewing of the demo i
had a part of my mind telling me that
what i was seeing was real
like i was watching a live action film
i think we've finally crossed the
threshold of photo realism and this is
thanks to the limits being removed from
game design
if i were to guess we're probably about
80 of the way to realism with this demo
it may just be that more iterative
improvements take us that extra 20
it was very fitting for this demo to be
done in collaboration with the makers of
the matrix trilogy it asks us to
question if what our eyes are seeing are
indeed real
i definitely know that i'll be
remembering this moment in computer
graphics for a long time
so what do you guys think are you
excited for the future of gaming or
something else what other applications
can you see this being used for let me
know in the comment section below if
you'd like to discuss this in further
detail head over to the cold fusion
discord the link will be in the
description below
so thanks for watching this has been
degogo and you have been watching cold
fusion if you did like this video feel
free to subscribe and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
it's me thinking
[Music]
you